21st
monday
the day the devil was [ __ ] in the
muffler and thrown into some river
somewhere off the coast of new york city
you bad [ __ ] kick a leak kick
that [ __ ] bouncingly oh
way keep [ __ ] up a pokey ass [ __ ] like
every single day
stop it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
special edition
audio's kicking
i'm stoned to the gills
and what you want to do what i got a
pocket full of rubbers and my homeboys
do too
oh [ __ ]
monday night [ __ ] get it together
east coast it's midnight i'm sorry i
know you gotta get up and go to work in
the morning
turn it off what the [ __ ] i realized
that after we left today i was like he
ate half of that 750 milligram
and i went home my plan was i only slept
four [ __ ] hours last night so my plan
was to when the podcast went ka puts i
was gonna go home eat something play
with the baby till nine then take a nap
i hung out with the baby like i always
do i watch those abc videos and all that
[ __ ]
and uh you know the wheels on the bus go
around then round the doors click click
click
i watched all that when i played with it
and then at nine o'clock i went in mean
gray i grabbed gray
and i said great we're taking a [ __ ]
nap [ __ ]
and i finally popped my head up at 10 to
10. i couldn't fall asleep so [ __ ] it i
got up
i wrote the end of the chapter i i sent
some emails
i got aggravated you know me doug it was
a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive then
you called me what happened oh [ __ ]
so that candy didn't work on you it's a
little bit but not really didn't take it
wasn't as good as a half a goomy no
no not
those gummies
okay as long as i knew but i was just i
thought i was gonna get high because it
started to kick in and i was driving
home from here because i had a piece of
equipment at my house
so i went i was driving home
on moorpark which it's this really small
street
and right at laurel canyon this cop
pulled up next to me and his side view
mirror hit mine
i just on the left-hand side i'm on
driver's side [ __ ] so i was like [ __ ]
and it wasn't me i was stopped and he
just hit it and i just like i froze it
was a red light and he he stopped and
when the green light came up i kind of
pulled up but i was like i think it's
okay guys and they were like pull over
let's make sure i was like [ __ ]
so i pulled up into a little
uh strip market i got out
and if it had been broken i probably
would have said let's just go because i
didn't i didn't want to be high i had a
[ __ ] anxiety attack paperwork so i i
just looked and look there was nothing
wrong with it um
but they like i just left and i got
paranoid but you didn't get a forget out
of jail free card and not know these
[ __ ] i should have done so i i
gotta do something all i imagined was
ari yelling at tsa i was like would he
[ __ ] yell to these guys
but i saw some i saw a video tonight of
like kids at a bar yelling at cops who
arresting their friends
and cops don't [ __ ] around anymore this
guy this cop tackled the kid and i was
like holy [ __ ] so i was like no
i'm just going to get out of here
somebody put a video of a deer
getting shot by a cop dude why don't you
people post those [ __ ] videos at
night
why is the insanity that some idiot
months ago posted the [ __ ] zebra
getting killed by the [ __ ] giraffe
i don't get what pete i don't like that
[ __ ] i don't want to see nobody
suffering you know you know you know
who's the worst and she's she's great
she melissa eva perez from san jose
every [ __ ] day on facebook two kids
kidnapped and burned and it's like no
yeah she's the kiss she loves
like why are you posting that stuff but
it's just uh it was a crazy day
but [ __ ] it we're back now we're back
i'm sorry about the audio today that
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens you know what i'm
saying i mean i can't control it i
didn't get any [ __ ] water is
unbelievable
no i'm straight but it was uh yeah i
went home my knee is [ __ ] up
i put ice on it when i went home when i
woke up i put level elevated and then
about one o'clock i got bored to death
about 12 30. in the heat of the sun i
went outside and started doing
kettlebell swings
just sweating then i [ __ ] started is
it okay for your knee cleans you know
what man i gotta do something to move
the blood around because i i walking
hurts a little bit and i was thinking of
hitting the bag at the y i just didn't
want to lose my parking spot these
[ __ ] by my house notorious dog
i'm [ __ ] anti-anxiety
i am anxiety written over my parking lot
i would rather sit home and eat nothing
than get in my [ __ ] car and lose that
parking spot i hold on to that mother
that's how you know you're getting
[ __ ] old oh yeah i'm doing two things
lately that are just embarrassing to
even talk about but i'm gonna talk about
what else are you doing i'm doing not
leaving the house because i don't want
to lose my parking spot yeah in front of
the house i like that spot in front of
the house i would kill a [ __ ]
for that
but i will walk to the bodega and get
like you know stupid [ __ ] so i don't
have to leave the house i got enough
food at the house
and i'm stealing
sweetness
from [ __ ] restaurants when i go on
the road you put them in a little napkin
in case they break my [ __ ]
it is the weirdest thing because every
coffee every [ __ ] hotel room i go
down on the road
has a cone egg or a [ __ ] coffee
machine but it's only like two sugars
and stuff they give you two [ __ ]
sugars like you're sitting there at
midnight trying to drink coffee watching
law in order and there's no [ __ ]
sugar so now you got to call room
service they won't open the door because
you got no do not disturb so it takes
them 20 minutes they go right back
downstairs and call you hire you do not
disturb someone is on then you come back
by the time i put the
thing in the coffee's goddamn cold so
what was the point i just got aggravated
yeah so i think i got a box of [ __ ]
sweet low at the house do you think i
put it in my suitcase [ __ ] no i leave it
at home every goddamn week and then i go
on the road and i realize at [ __ ] 12
o'clock that i need a little coffee
because i like drinking coffee at night
one cup before i go to bed i sleep like
a [ __ ] soldier nice because it takes
me up and then right down like crash
bubble
okay you follow the fact that's old
school mentality it's cocaine days you
gotta go up what goes up must come down
[ __ ] that's when i was testing the
audio and waterbots are called just
because i was bored i didn't want to
talk to myself and he was telling me a
good wing because i was like he was
telling me how he does the edibles and
he goes out i'm like how do you do it he
says he drinks like an energy drink
right after he eats the edible so it's
like it's like a
heroin brings down cocaine brings you up
it's like a little mix so that's how he
walks around
that's good for him i don't know the
water bottle him jump out did he call
the podcast he just called me i was just
testing the audio he wanted to see what
was crack-a-lacking yeah i put it up on
twitter but something weird happened
today uh
i i was never really emotional
but as i get older i want to hear what
you have to say about 25 what old about
well i don't know i'm older that's where
everyone says everyone says i'm young
but i feel old um
the
boston
bombing thing they had all the videos
today of the marathon i started getting
teary eyed i wasn't there for it but
just seeing the pictures and the people
hugging like you weren't in new york for
9 11.
but how did that affect you i was pissed
really
i didn't get pissed that morning i was
pissed later on because uh
i know what it does to people those
people that were walking around that day
you know i got pissed when i heard the
stories and i'm taking the ferry over
like they were just [ __ ] frozen i
can't imagine
being at the boston marathon last year
that wasn't one of the most thoughtless
[ __ ] things who knows why they did it
who the [ __ ] knows these people nowadays
yeah who the [ __ ] knows
i did stupid [ __ ] when i was 21. i would
never
think of doing something like that for
kicks but who knows what their motives
were and uh
whatever and they have a show on ng
whatever discovering
national geographic about them getting
caught did you see it from nice yeah
pretty [ __ ] interesting how they they
shot the kid and blah blah blah and the
other kid went into a [ __ ] boat and
hid and uh how the pictures they the fbi
saw the pictures and when the bomb went
off those two didn't move
yeah that's how they knew it was them it
was very interesting how the fbi catches
you and now you know man we got [ __ ]
cameras everywhere got cameras
everywhere you have to assume there's a
camera watching you at all times even a
black and white little [ __ ] porno
camera that won't see your dick or your
hair but it sees you and [ __ ] show
you in court you know some guy will come
in and clear it up in [ __ ] court so
who the hell knows lee i just my heart
goes out so the boston marathon was
today correct yeah it was today and
you know what i'm gonna piss some people
off but
and tell me if i'm wrong tell me but
just seeing all those people out there
it's something i don't see out here i
don't know what it is but east coast
people in the towns like there was so
much pride for boston
and i just it made me it made me like i
started tearing up
and i just made
i don't feel that out here for people
from this city
so maybe i'm wrong maybe i just don't
don't interact with it's an empty city
man
yeah i have a lot of problems with this
city i have a lot of problem with
friendships in this city and how they
work how
everything is to let people know that
they know you after that there's no
friendship there's no friendship
you know uh when i grew up those were
friends i had around me those
[ __ ] i could count on them for
anything i had a great time with them
when i went out you know when i went out
i had a good time with them from the
heart
here i see people for a few hours and i
feel their [ __ ] death
i feel because maybe things aren't going
their way
when i'm around people who sold their
[ __ ] soul
i leave them and i leave i feel like
[ __ ] for three or four [ __ ] days
people sell their [ __ ] souls that's
the people you [ __ ] people clap for
and cheer for and jump up and down for
these people sold their souls you're
like joey what do you mean the devil
showed up with a pen
no no
somewhere along the line they over they
ignored something something natural that
comes over you because they thought what
they were doing is is completely
better than what somebody like you uh
somebody at home is doing you know they
have this heir to them that they're
better than everybody because they have
three dollars or because they're on tv
or because they've done a movie and i've
never understood that
for me it's always been about the job
for me it's not because i'm betting
anybody i'm lucked out i'm not even
close to doing that [ __ ]
but i i i just that's what i don't like
about it and that's why when you go to a
dodger game people leaving the sixth
[ __ ] inning
you know that's the big knock about the
dodger games and yeah parking is hard
and walking out of there's hard but it's
like that they're uh
johnny come lately fans there's a word
for those type of people it's like
bandwagon it's like after the boston red
sox one the boston red sox hat now is
[ __ ] as big as the yankee hat maybe
you know because everybody wants to wear
boston for years when they were losing
nobody wore a boston red sox hat you
understand me uh it's amazing the
loyalty that we have here we have no
loyalty like i said it's between me
getting the job or you getting the job
i'm bad [ __ ] lee to get the job
even though i've known you for 15
[ __ ] years you know yeah i i look at
this town i can tell you i probably have
four close friends you know and you're
one of them you know what i'm saying
ari i mean
that the rest are just [ __ ]
acquaintances because i know
i look at somebody and i know if i ever
gotten a beef and i had to call them to
bail me out the cash wouldn't be that
they'd hang up and make up a story how
they couldn't get the atm card didn't
work and then i would look at them weird
i would never look at them the same way
so that's why i don't even put them
close to me because i know these people
aren't worth their weight in gold
it's [ __ ] amazing that the things you
hear out here and the things that you go
through out here and the commitment
level on different levels of acting and
stand up and
you know how for some people this is a
flash in the past and they you see them
three years later they don't even do
this no more that they're doing
something completely different now
because this was too hard or this is for
[ __ ] so you got to be gay to be in
hollywood you know you don't need comics
and
and you see them years later or are you
still out there
and then maybe yeah i'm still out here
[ __ ] doing nothing
in the sun lifting [ __ ] kettlebells
while you're out here sweating your
[ __ ] life off i got insurance i got a
[ __ ] pension i wasn't supposed to
have things like that you heard my
[ __ ] story you know what i'm saying
so i don't know
yeah i understand where you're coming
from i don't give a [ __ ] if you get heat
no and there's some solid people out
there all right it's not the people but
and it's maybe it's because i i i've met
a lot of people that aren't in the
entertainment business that are very
solid oh yeah when i go to towns like
whittier and all those places to do
comedy i meet some [ __ ] people do
they have la pride like i just
from coming from boston and stuff i
always like when it comes to but then
again you know when you go to a lego
game it's more to be seen
that's what people understand about out
here it's but that's going on with the
next two god forbid you don't have the
first three rows in the nick game and
people can't see you on tv and you're
drinking a beer and you're cheering and
you're young you know i i never saw
what that's all about i'd rather stay
home i'd rather be on some [ __ ] i'd
rather be out on a [ __ ] couch with
you smoking a joint
talking about stupidity about a podcast
or something that's been the way with me
constantly yeah it's it's really
surprising when people go i want to go
into the green room or i want to hang
with you guys after a show listen
since i've known rogan i don't do
nothing
they used to go to strip clubs and then
as the years they progress they go to a
bar then we go back to the hotel and
then you start doing less and less
things you know there's no [ __ ] party
here it's amazing how it's i said that
in tempe we were sitting there after the
show and everyone was just quiet in the
room and
and like after the show you're like
you're hungry and i was like man and he
didn't know we just went back to our
rooms and i was like this is like i
thought it was gonna be a big party and
and and go and hang out to five in the
morning the comedy show yeah that's the
[ __ ] part the party is doing the show
and then going home like i've said a
thousand times for years i would
consider those things real party and
after economy should i go party and
guess what by saturday night you're
paying 22 to come see me and i'm sucking
yeah i'm sucking because i'm tired
my my [ __ ] mind's not straight and
that's what happened to me for [ __ ]
years man
waiting people just get funny no they
put all the elements together
maybe they were funny and they couldn't
put a joke together maybe i could put a
joke together but the dedication of my
commitment yeah there's so many things
then comes a point where one day you get
sick and tired of being sick and dying
and you put
five of the seven elements together and
you move a little forward yeah and
that's what you helped me do that's what
we did you understand me but that's that
that the whole uh
thing of it and that's with boxing
that's what happened with rob robbie
lawler you've been around for 12 [ __ ]
years knocking [ __ ] out getting
beat up getting submitted comes back to
the ufc the guy's got a fire in his eye
okay he just lost the last fight for a
championship round but he's 32 years old
he's not going anywhere he learned from
that fight he learned the same way how
when johnny hendricks lost to gsp he
learned yeah i'm sorry i'm using the mma
things but you learn
you learn as you go across and even if
you lose trying something
now you know when you attack it again
you know what to look out for yeah you
know there's people that try to escape
from cuba all the time
and maybe the the the the [ __ ] float
won't last past 50 miles now they got to
go back to the drawing board we got to
wear more glue
you know
but you know you're not going to get
everything the first time and today i
learned today i was thinking about it
today how big experience was because
when i got home i was thinking about it
we i didn't really panic when this
happened the biggest thing
i complained about those jobs i had
but the big like you learn
that stuff is gonna happen and if you
freak out
if if you how if you overreact it it
hurts you on one level on
at least for me if i overreact and i
start getting worked up and i start
playing with everything i'm not going to
see like when you lose something at your
house i always run around and you pull
everything apart you throw everything
around you sit you like
you relax relax
you breathe and you retrace your steps
and you'll find your [ __ ] keys it's
amazing i do it especially
even with cell phones oh yeah cell
phones i walked out of cars and go what
the [ __ ] i left myself right there
it really is amazing so you know people
want to try [ __ ] and it doesn't succeed
it takes years
to be a good comic the way it takes she
used to be a good fighter it takes years
to be a good writer but that's the thing
like you probably even even when you
were sucking 15 years ago
you learn something at one show that
comes up now and you're like oh i'm not
gonna be freaked out about you no no no
i remember being in jacksonville florida
and going on into the audience and
seeing i used to judge the audience
i used to judge the [ __ ] audience and
it used to judge me and that bomb
so do you understand me i go out there
and i go look at all those older people
with white hair
they're not gonna like my material i
just lost
i just got hit with the biggest punch
which is i lost before i even went on
that yeah and then i go i won't look at
them and it was just so many things i
would eat [ __ ] because i wouldn't do my
material i'd speed through the joke
i wouldn't take my time
and now i see old people you saw what
happened in tempe yeah those old people
that were there and i went out there and
saw him and i go i'm gonna pull it back
and i go [ __ ] no i'm gonna open up this
[ __ ] valve because you can
always
close the valve but you can't open it
once you you follow him saying to you
it's like acting when you're going to
audition and you walk in
sometimes if you go in and the character
is loud and you go in there the first
time
he's going to get mad directly because
you're not loud enough or you're not
your energy isn't that high okay i can't
do nothing with you if your energy's
high coming in i could push it backwards
yeah but if you're not you're following
yeah the the state of mind we're talking
about late night church of what's
happening now monday april 21st where's
tony bennecock sucker there's no tony
bennett what happened you're slipping
this is what i'm talking about
where is it it's coming hold on it's
coming it's not it's supposed to be
[ __ ] lined up and prepared i'm sorry
we came up late today the audio but who
the [ __ ] i'm not sorry [ __ ] happened i
hope your [ __ ] stayed up monday
is monday we got till midnight to put
this together i'm still gonna fire you
up you're still gonna go out there on
tuesday i'm gonna stab [ __ ] the
neck it's the church with the jew
how
where's the water
oh
what's up [ __ ]
you're home
you gonna kick that up a little bit okay
fine what the [ __ ] you got me over here
like i'm deaf you're gonna eat the rest
of that candy and throw it away and
leave it there for the ends i'll leave
it i mean
any other [ __ ] to eat here we got not
lazy no no
i'll bring you something strong when oh
good
we got edge juarez going nice
he hasn't called it no i love that
suarez to
see how he does it what's going on with
turn that [ __ ] off what's going on
i already a little candle for the old
lady i put some glasses of water up
you know i get it i'm done out of the
[ __ ] way easy what's going on with
you my brother i just [ __ ]
and i i know we've talked about this a
lot but
the weight thing for me is it's always
been there like i've never what'd you do
with that pot roast i know you ate that
no it's it's in my car
it's gone now yeah you might as well
just dump it because you cautious well
no because so here's like it's
i i ha everyone i think everyone has
their addiction sort of thing
and for me it's
i think part of it's an addiction i
think most of it's laziness honestly
but ever ever since like like you and
terry
it must just get to a point after a
bunch of years where you don't go out as
much but ever since i started going out
like i put the weight back on and i just
luckily i have i think the thing that
some people don't have like when you go
on tv and you see like the to a thousand
pound person
is i luckily when i get to a certain
point i'm like okay i gotta bring this
back i'm
trust me i i shouldn't let it get to
this point but it's uh
luckily i i feel like i have that in my
brain where
i'm not i don't think i could get to a
thousand pounds i probably could but
it's just uh so i've been working on
that
i uh i've talked to people about joining
a gym
i would love to get a bike but the
people around here are crazy so i don't
i don't know what i'm going to do i i
just start with walking
it all starts
you're not going to go if you can't walk
you're not going to go
if you don't walk you're not gonna go to
the [ __ ] gym
just trust me you can't get yourself to
walk
what's gonna get you to get you in a car
to drive to a [ __ ] gym to be around
people who look like david and goliath
to [ __ ] work out yeah you got to
start walking and that's what i'm saying
i haven't been pushing i've been telling
you go for a walk
for the last two months what have i been
telling you no and it's cool it's the
easy it's the easiest world [ __ ] about
what's going on or who you're busy you
get out of here at nine o'clock
the car ain't going nowhere
walk the tent planet
go read the [ __ ] wall and walk back
that's it this isn't hard today with my
bad knee i was sitting there i wrote i
emailed i'm sitting i'm like what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do
i sat outside i tried to write a joke
i'm like what the [ __ ] am i gonna do i
went upstairs i took two [ __ ] baby
aspirins
it was about 12 15. i went downstairs i
rotated my knees in all directions
i did these hip things i [ __ ]
stressed a little bit and i said [ __ ] it
you know the knee's going to hurt
whether or not i work out or not yeah i
might as well work out a little bit i'm
not going to jump [ __ ] ladders and be
johnny goombah but i'm going to work get
the blood going i did ten sets of swings
and i did [ __ ] five sets of six sets
of
cleaning jerks i got nice and sweaty
took me 35 minutes i picked up a 45-35
walked 50 yards and 50 yards back and i
put the weights in the car and i was
done for the day yeah and i don't you
know what i didn't eat sugar today
you know i ate that that [ __ ]
chocolate bar and i ate two of those
things with 10 calories a piece
i don't drink soda no more i was telling
my wife that the only way not to give
your child
to stop your child from drinking soda
is by not drinking soda in front of them
yeah i had
my mom made a mistake with me you know
it was funny i took my friend ed
broncaccio to the fights with me this
weekend he also came to the show i
haven't seen eddie
in probably 25 years and uh he lives in
orlando and he contacted me about a
month ago and we were going back and
forth and i got him tickets for the show
and then joe said you have you want to
take some of the ufc's or him tickets
and we're talking on the phone he goes
just do your friends and the people you
talk to know how spoiled you were when
you were a kid
and i go yeah i think they know you know
i've said it a thousand times to people
i love my mother
i miss my mother if i tell you that
after 30 something years i don't miss my
mother when people talk about their moms
and don't tight with them i get pissed
off at them because i don't have a mom
you only get one shot of being a good
son
and i failed at that you know god knows
how she's looking at me from up there
whether she's in her health i don't
think she failed it there
and uh well i didn't go to you know i
didn't do what her dreams were whatever
but uh
if my mother wouldn't have passed away i
would have been a different human being
altogether
i don't think i would have been doing
what i'm doing now
you know for me to become what i'm doing
now i had my ass lit under the fire
you know we talk about all the time
about our mutual friend we have a mutual
friend that will not quit his job
and he's lived in this town for 15 years
and he's had very minimal success
and the guy is talented but i'm telling
you it's because he hasn't
quit his job
because he doesn't have the iron the
fire under his [ __ ] ass
so whenever he goes into those audition
rooms or he does all that [ __ ] he goes
all the way to the end
his mind doesn't take the mile because
they're comfortable
and he's never going to move forward
until he quits that job never it's going
to be he never gonna book nothing
when he goes in there and that hunger is
shown that hunger it shows for a reason
man and people buy it like if you're
selling something and people see you
desperate they smell it on you yeah but
when you're an actor or you're a comic
or you're
that desperation becomes motivation
do you fall i'm saying that desperation
becomes motivation
if i have a grammar blow and i gotta
sell it to you to eat tonight i'm gonna
sell you that grandma blow
do you understand what what what i was
lacking in my career as a stand-up comic
wasn't the funniness it was that i
wasn't selling nothing i wasn't telling
nobody about it
i wasn't telling nobody what was this
podcast gave me the first level of
telling some people what was in my heart
and if you get on board or you don't
writing and tweeting and [ __ ] like that
tells people and i say some [ __ ] up
things but my heart's in the right place
yeah you know what i'm saying
so it's just uh
it's just really weird that i would have
been a complete different personally
because i was soft man
but because my ass was lit under the
fire you know i understand i still don't
wear underwear today i wear i have a box
under a thousand brand new ones and i
want them to work out because all my
dick looking like arnolds and [ __ ] you
know my remember they took a picture of
him on tmz with his dick moving around
in santa monica that's why you wear
underwear and
but the reason all those years i didn't
wear otherwise because i knew i could do
without
i got to learn what you could do without
me you can move forward that's why
people tell me i need to do this i look
at them and go what are you talking
about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you know my uncle who we did the
interview here with that time my uncle
gave me the biggest lesson in life and
he's like i'll help you
i'll help you with what's coming to you
but all your luxuries you're not gonna
get a dime out of me weed booze the
movies
you know i'll give you a place to stay
and i'll [ __ ] feed you and that's
what
you know i had to learn how to get on my
own a lot of people don't know how to do
that we had this discussion today a lot
of people don't know how to leave in the
daytime at 8 in the morning come back
with 50 bucks i will leave this
[ __ ] tomorrow at 8 in the
morning i'll come back with 48 bucks but
i'll come back with something even if i
gotta rob a [ __ ] purse at five
o'clock
because that's the way you know when i
was out there that's how i was banging
it so now i took that same energy and i
twist it over to this and i put it into
stand-up for years when i was out here
that's why i don't understand when
stand-ups go away on the weekend i don't
know about weddings i don't know about i
don't know about these things you know
we had an interesting talk this morning
about guys with sports
that when i was in boston some guy came
up to me he's like not for nothing you
ever heard dean on your [ __ ] show you
know why don't you ask him about the
early calls you know it's ruining mma
and i looked i'm like oh don't you owe
you a credit card
do you not owe credit card money yet
then why are you worried about her dean
he ain't worried about you [ __ ] he
ain't worried about you these guys that
are into sports and they call up i took
the third draft pitch of me do you owe
money yeah then what are you doing on
the phone you're talking about sports
you [ __ ] momo
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and i
learned what was important and what
wasn't important and what you could do
without that's why a year ago i was
telling you on a sunday i don't know
what it is to sit in front of a [ __ ]
when i went to the ufc this week with
joe i'm very thankful that he gave me a
ticket and i went and sat but by the
third fight there's got to be something
else i could be doing to make [ __ ]
three dollars there's got to be
something people at home are like joey
don't you relax well [ __ ] relax what
[ __ ] relaxed that's what the problem
is with people everybody wants to
[ __ ] relax everybody wants to go on
vacation everybody thinks they have a
vacation coming to them i've never seen
nothing like this in my life people i
have friends that go away in jersey
every eight months like like they think
they have a vacation coming to him then
you talk to him they tell you how rough
life is
yeah but you know we're saving money
because it's tight right now he got his
uh overtime cut then what the [ __ ] you
doing in bali yeah what the [ __ ] you
doing in bali if you got your overtime
cut i don't understand prioritizing in
life you know
so
we'll be talking about lee what do you
get it's just uh you get me over here
and [ __ ] i mean i i don't know what it
is for other people and we were talking
about it and it's just i could i could
blame food addiction and i think that's
part of it you got no food addiction you
got no food addiction
definitely they don't eat in the morning
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're eating
i know you're eating chocolate bars
somewhere you know but i tell you what
the problem is like you don't want to
move i love you like my brother and for
the love of christ i've never seen
anything like that i'm a i work hard but
i'm a lazy [ __ ] i i love you
cannot yeah we live in california
how the [ __ ] are you this day's like
have you been out in the sun no and you
giggle
and i gotta tell you
ain't nothing funny yeah it's
embarrassing like i just wanna before
you haven't showered
oh well that was this weekend i showered
no i don't give a [ __ ] you gotta you
gotta wash that ass when you wake up in
the morning that's part of being you
know cleanliness is next to godliness
and then at four you gotta take another
shower even if you didn't do nothing
that [ __ ] gets stinky and those balls
get [ __ ] stinky you never spend a
weekend if you're not if your wife isn't
home not in a million [ __ ] years when
i allow that to happen now that you have
it at two o'clock in the night you
scratch that nut and smell your fingers
and see if you're gonna go to bed with
that stink nut on your [ __ ] are you
crazy
no i mean are you [ __ ] crazy i agree
with a lot of what you say
sometimes that's part of getting up
that's probably getting more true that's
true that's part of getting moving how
can you not take a shower that's part of
the whole movement that gets you going
the blood hits the circulation you bend
over you wipe your ass you clean your
toes that's the [ __ ] initial you put
your clothes on you go out you see the
sun you say lord thank you for giving me
a [ __ ] another day in this miserable
[ __ ] life i'm gonna take this and i'm
gonna make this day into something and
you walk around the block and you're
back in a half hour and you moved and
now that doesn't give you a green light
to go eat a [ __ ] yum yum donut like i
used to do i used to walk the yum yum
donuts that's not a bad move
you know you're coming plus that's
something i want to do
sure but if that's what it takes to get
you out of the house yeah then so be
if you tell you me and terry used to do
it way before when we [ __ ] moved up
here and i was staying on the walking
bench before my knees got [ __ ] up we
would walk every night to young male get
it done and then walk home
yeah that's i have to get i've never had
i've never gotten in the habit of i i'm
in the habit of hanging out and and
being on the computer and watching tv i
need to get in the habit of getting out
i feel like if you do it every day then
it doesn't feel like it's hard and dog
right from here yeah right from here
there's no you gotta know where to go at
nine right from here diagonals coming at
ten you're sitting here in this [ __ ]
darkness get out go for a walk down the
tenth planet ten planet bird break is
down the corner go see little dragons
down there jumping up and down and you
walk back
and it's what it's 20 minutes when you
really think about it and it's weird
because i like walking to that weed
store about my house and sometimes if
i'm right in the morning i go [ __ ] it at
10 o'clock i'll walk over to the weed
store even if i don't need wheat
i'm not smoking weed i just walk over
and get like a cookie yeah put it in my
desk just to get me out me that's why
just to get me out i was always big but
that i i put weight on here because in
boston i'd walk i had to walk everywhere
no there's not here it's it's very weird
but
you know i don't know
what are you gonna do in a gym if you
join the gym what exercise are you gonna
do what are you gonna focus on is it's
just cardio so biking i've heard spin
class is really fun
i see that's the thing i i don't even
know where to start
i just i honestly just need
cardio right now i think just walk just
start with walking on 30 after you walk
30 days
then we'll go join the gym and we'll see
where you're at then something that you
know
to have a beginner's class to get you in
slowly you know you're not gonna you're
a young guy so in a year you'll be in a
lot better shape than i'm in no matter
what the [ __ ] you do you know what i'm
saying i'm not even in good shape i'm
just saying that that's why i try to do
cardio but i'm still breathing heavy i'm
not gonna lie to nobody you know that's
why i was on that dog thing for a while
because i felt like it would force me to
get out of the house
but it just it's so much
so much responsibility i wouldn't want
now now what do they know if i don't go
out get out of the house they have the
[ __ ] uh the pee pee pads it drives me
nuts so people don't leave the house now
with the dogs and it's just uh
it's it's it's this is it's a really
it's a lazy culture [ __ ] they have
those websites you can get food
delivered 24 hours a day it's an easy
thing to do to put on the weight it's
[ __ ]
you don't i if i didn't want to i i
could not leave the house in the back of
your mind yeah do you think at times
television and media wants you to be
heavy [ __ ] yeah because then you're out
you're already feeling that you're
watching tv
if
you i mean i'm not really big into
conspiracy theories but if you're not
out there protesting or if you're not
out there
if you're just sitting at home watching
tv
looking at the ads you're not really
you're not
doing anything you're not gonna notice
them doing stuff
you're gonna you know you're not gonna
get mad at them for doing stuff i really
think that like i really think
entertainment
is a way to make us especially with the
phones it's a way to make us not notice
things like especially at the airport
when everyone's looking at their phone
that's why i think people don't get mad
at tsa because you're kind of
just doing that that's why i don't put
facebook i have twitter on my phone
i have a hotmail on my phone that's it
all those other avenues i do not have on
my phone i don't want to be on my phone
all day i don't want to be part of the
internet all [ __ ] day
that's why i do what i got to do in the
[ __ ] morning and i get to [ __ ] off
that yeah to [ __ ] off that because this
you know what if you do look look at it
all day there ain't nothing on there
no no no there's nothing nothing on it
nothing that has nothing no lindsay
lohan lost her kid while she was shoe
she lost 18 [ __ ] kids she didn't blow
for 30 [ __ ] years all sudden she lost
their kids she didn't have sperm in it
you know that was in the big thing and
people learn it at work
because
there's no real the biggest thing i've
learned doing this is yeah i'm making
less money but i'm happier and i get
more done there's no reason to be in an
office for 40 hours 60 hours a week no a
lot of that time is spent on the
internet
so [ __ ] you finally you find the
things you go look at menus yelp is
great but yelp a lot of people are just
looking at the foods and
it's uh how many times i've looked at
yelp
none
of the times i looked at instagram none
i don't have instagram yet that's it
it's ridiculous you let come into your
life to distract you what you left to
come into your life
to distract you and there's things that
you know you have to do you just refuse
to do i talk about me i've been having a
lot more success lately when i just open
up my page to write and when i connect
it to twitter and facebook
oh a little something for the [ __ ]
late night crowd you know what i'm
saying let's take
oh yeah
tremendous i'm going to mark that chair
for when we move that's your chair you
like that hot [ __ ] sucker it's probably
marked already it's probably melting
that's the leather is melting the
corinthian leather yeah but uh what are
we talking about just how how uh
[ __ ] up
technology is and the thing is it's kind
of like what you were talking about
earlier where people
who get entitled when they sell their
soul
it's really [ __ ] easy
and it's really [ __ ] entertaining now
to watch a clip or watch a movie or or
or do all that stuff on your phone
and it's it's
it would be better not to the biggest
thing for me i don't sit on the couch i
go home i have my laptop and my phone on
my bed and i have a tv in the bedroom
that's even worse yeah it's terrible
it's i have to get out of there i don't
spend any time in my living room i'm in
my bed it's just it's comfortable and
it's [ __ ] easy
and you gotta get out of there how many
bags of chips you got around there
i don't have any yeah i don't know yes i
mean you got jelly beans i have no
enough butter i have no food in my in my
room but paula yelled at me because i
wanted to get a mini fridge for drinks
in my room and she's like you can't
[ __ ] have it's two steps it's ten
steps to the fridge i was like okay but
i thought about it i wanted a [ __ ]
meal
yeah yeah you know
i can't believe
some of this [ __ ] i i can't believe it's
not
maybe it's a generation gap
you know maybe it's uh but i can't
believe it at times
and it's getting worse i i honestly
think it's getting worse that app people
told you about vine the video one
there's six year old kids on it
so that none they're they're parents who
maybe aren't home with their kids or
they have to work too much
and i think people are just getting kids
are just gonna get fatter
honestly i think
in a few years i mean they that's why at
movie theaters they're pretty new seats
in this because people are too fat too
fat to sit in them and they have to put
bigger cup holders in it it's amazing
i don't remember coming from cube i
don't remember that [ __ ] but i remember
my mom going you know you could stay in
front of the house
and it went you know you went out all
day yeah i never did that you went out
at eight in the morning and you played
till 12 and you went up and got a
sandwich
then you went back outside and you
played again until dinner time and then
if you were lucky your mom will let you
go right back out and you ran and every
day you pushed down them across on the
street i'm across on broadway in new
york city my mom going do not cross
broadway what
as soon as she stuck her head back
inside i counted the ten i would run
right to the corner and we'd run across
the street and run back that's why when
i see these lazy [ __ ]
waiting for a light and walking like
dump the dump
[ __ ] go crazy like the ones that by
the library when i'm walking over you
know those things that they have those
yellow things across the street yeah you
have to stop your [ __ ] car and
there's always some kid with a backpack
walking i should be running across the
[ __ ] street like i used to run across
the street there was no 30-second light
that blinked and told you 28 27 stop you
ran across that [ __ ] there was
no instruction you took a chance [ __ ]
yeah you took a [ __ ] chance you know
so now you don't uh
i did all that and then when we moved to
jersey it was until 10 o'clock at night
until 10 o'clock at night when i was in
fort lauder i was talking to kathleen
keltoes and she goes i remember
you hearing the basketball they lived
right next to the basketball court and
my father having to go out there and go
guys really and it was you and he would
see [ __ ] coco he won't go home
you know when i wanted to be good at
basketball i knew there was only one way
to be good at basketball you had to play
[ __ ] basketball yeah jerry west took
300 jump shots a day
300 boom beside the games and the
running and the riding the bike and the
layups and the [ __ ] sprint thing he
took 300 jump shots a day that means he
jumped 300 [ __ ] times a day i did
that every day for four [ __ ] years
five [ __ ] years from the seventh
grade to like junior year in high school
even when i wasn't playing i would get a
ball and go out there in the winter when
i would i would shovel the [ __ ]
courts you want me to get people to call
in here and tell you how me and chucky
mcbreen used to shovel the [ __ ]
better yet
we'd walk to like a court that had good
competition and we shovel the court so
the kids in that neighbor could come out
we could play against them i'm gonna
have chucky call in to tell you what the
[ __ ] we were doing at 14 in the eighth
grade when i graduated in eighth grade
was one of the snowiest years ever
i didn't graduate in the eighth grade
because i had to go to five star
basketball camp and it started like june
28th you were out of school by june 10th
but it snowed so much in 78 that we were
in school to the end of [ __ ] june oh
wow and it snowed but we think guys like
me and chucky and whitey o'donnell and
mahoney and david ruiz we stayed in [ __ ]
no as soon as they call school night we
call get your gloves [ __ ] we wear
gloves every it was so cold that the
ball wouldn't bounce
you know when oxygen in the [ __ ] ball
will not bounce that's how cold it was
out that's hysterical so i mean that's
and so it started them with me
when i got to be about
my junior year i went from uh once my
mother died and i started lifting
weights with those guys my appetite went
nuts
and i went up to one 194 and one summer
i wanted a can i went on a tuna fish
american cheese and milkshake diet the
whole summer i would drink a protein
shake in the morning i scoop ice cream
16 ounces of milk three scoops of
protein four eggs wheat germ
[ __ ] everything in that thing vitamin
c fish liver oil and i just guzzle it to
yoohoo i guzzle it down and then i eat a
can of tuna with crackers with no
mayonnaise just hot sauce for lunch you
have no [ __ ] idea i used to live with
danny biancolo you know danny that calls
here when i told the story about me
sweating on his cousin when i was up
doing the [ __ ] upside down uh bench
presses and i had a sweat bead on my
nose
and when i went to hand on the weight
the bead went off my nose and into his
[ __ ] mouth i mean this is uh so when
did you start putting the weight on
when i moved to los angeles when i moved
in and doug stanhope has a picture of me
in 97 that i was about
2 35
then i immediately went up to about 265.
because you're [ __ ] driving and it's
and i was okay but i was also bad sleep
mm-hmm bad sleep contributes to it not
drinking enough water i wasn't taking
vitamins zero exercise
zero muscle because the more muscle you
build
so right now you're 25 you could start
lifting weights for your weight loss
program you think so i know so because
you're going to lift light weights and
do reps so you [ __ ] burn that fat you
burn
lifting weights see i don't even know
this is how stupid i am yeah lifting
weights burns fat because it's
lightweight five sets of six builds
muscle mass if you drink protein you
know okay people argue it's 30 grams of
protein five times a day to gain muscle
mass like real muscle mass you know now
they have protein shakes that are 42
grams of protein
58 grams of protein when i was into it
it was 30 grams of protein per meal 50
grams and that's a lot like if you look
at a can of tuna and two eggs it's 15
[ __ ] grams you still got to eat
what's going on does it sound bad
because you're looking at it like
somebody took your ten dollars
uh
and and that's what it is so
like when i went on this when i was
started at this weight loss it was 4 18
and what i do is i go to the gym to the
ymca and i'd ride the bike every day
morning yeah that's right first and then
there was three minutes my friend i was
sweating
breathing heavy dizziness saying i
wasn't gonna come back in there but
every week i do an extra minute and you
start doing a three and then i would go
on the punching bag and i wouldn't move
my feet i would just move my hips
so i would be going you know like from
here to here boom and i'd just be moving
i do it for 30 minutes and that's it and
i stuck to my weight watcher points yeah
i wasn't eating edibles and that easy it
was [ __ ] it was very surprising how
easy it is and i understood
why people
just said [ __ ] it i understand
because nobody knows where to really
start right
it's hard
especially for people who have never
done it
it's it's a lot easier to do what you've
been doing
and it's uh and it sounds like i'm
complaining i'm not i don't mean to
complain about or whine about it it's
just
it's never been who i i'm always gonna
be a bigger guy i'm never gonna be
a weight lifter guy
but i wanna i do want to be
a healthier bad guy i can't walk from
here to the car and be sweating
profusiously you can't do that i
understand like i said for years i lived
across the street from the ymca and i
wouldn't go you know what the thing that
got me this weekend was when we went to
vegas i
just by the grace of god didn't need the
sea bald extender and like it clicked i
was like [ __ ] i don't if i need the seat
belt extender that's [ __ ]
that's that's a bad thing so like okay
let's hit that level again have you did
you ever have to use that for you [ __ ]
yeah
all the time when she was showing it i
call her over
and she was showing them poops
give that donkey to joey now i got three
or four inches it's [ __ ] amazing yeah
it's amazing and it was getting tight
there for a while for about three months
ago it was tight there when terry had
the baby
it was tight a little longer than three
months ago
it's uh it really is [ __ ] amazing man
the weight thing with this country but
it's just uneducated you know people are
just uneducated nothing it's nothing to
do with laziness once you understand how
easy it is that you have to burn more
than what you put in yeah and you find
tricks like if you gotta eat three
apples to get started then you eat three
apples bro yeah
you know one thing about weight watchers
i learned that's one of the greatest
things if you're not hungry enough to
eat an apple and you ain't hungry right
you know then you're really you know
it's a beautiful [ __ ] statement you
know
it's funny how you this weekend i was uh
writing and i'm writing this
autobiography
i was thinking about how i really never
had anything about the latter years
i have all the things in the early
development of what i was trying to
accomplish which i had no [ __ ] idea
but i had no
uh
nothing later on and something on the
plane
was a long [ __ ] plane ride to a land
i was writing and it made me think about
1993
and what my life was like and how simple
it was and how
that's when the beginning of this
started
so so where were you 93 okay so
in 91 i separated from my wife for 90.
91 90 october 90.
by 91 i was doing comedy i think
oh no no no
91 october 91 i separated from her and i
decided to go for it and then i went
into a cocaise and pills
and i went back east and i stayed with
georgie and mike ronnie for a while
and then i uh
got my life together a little bit and i
realized how badly i want to do comedy
and i was frustrated
you know there's nothing worse than
having a dream and you're [ __ ]
frustrated
you want that dream to speed up you know
you just wanted to get to a place where
at least you're coping here
and i knew that i had a you know when i
was in new york those months i was in
new york for nine months i'd hang out on
stage eight times
and i'd walk around telling people i was
a comedian but i was just you know the
addiction had me and every time i go to
do
comedy i'd stop in the city and buy coke
and by the time i got to the club i'd do
a line of coke and then run leave oh
jesus you have no [ __ ] idea so for
you people are trying to get into
anything whether it's playing the piano
or going back to school you know we all
[ __ ] procrastinate i don't want you
to think that we don't you know uh one
of the purposes of this podcast is
we're off we all put our pants on one
leg at a [ __ ] time i'm sick and tired
of this people looking down and saying
who gives a [ __ ]
and uh
i went back and i got this apartment i
dated this girl and
she lived upstairs and she had moved out
one day i seen the landlord and he liked
me when i was dating her and i go he
goes well yeah what's going on i'm
looking for a place because i'm renting
my down place 400 a month
and it was basically the rocky apartment
okay it was basically rocky's apartment
it was a small kitchen a refrigerator a
living room with a door and the bed the
bedroom was so small
there was no room in the bedroom in the
bedroom it was just a bed you just
opened the door yeah the door didn't
open
door off the hinges
the door covered that's how small i
would just go to the bed and fall over
yeah and walk to the side and i had an
air conditioner i bought it for 100
bucks cheap and the apartment worked for
me you know it was a and i think about
that apartment if i ever made money i
was gonna go buy that apartment because
there were so many aspects of that
apartment that first of all the walls
were littered with cocaine
oh yeah was it the one you threw a
little cocaine into the wall i thought
you should throw the empty packages at
one night i said there's gotta be
cocaine in one of the bags i ripped the
wall down
and the landlord was like what happened
he hung on the wall got wet
and it was also where my dream of comedy
came from
it was [ __ ] bad
like it was just bad i would go do these
rooms at night and i was dedicated at
the time at that time i knew what i
wanted to do i knew what needed to be
done
you know i'd started comedy in uh
july of 91
it was january of 94 and i had to
[ __ ] do something
you know my ex-wife was barking on me i
was i was night i was uh 31 years old at
that time i was doing comedy three years
i wasn't really even committed to comedy
i was just telling people that's why i'm
okay with jujitsuna because even if i go
to jiu jitsu once a week
i know as long as i go
that's the most important thing you know
i wanted to go to class tonight i know
my knee wouldn't hold it i have an
audition tomorrow at 11 o'clock for a
great movie i'll tell you about a second
okay and i don't know if i'll make 12 30
class but i'll do it i'll do something
tomorrow hit the bag and then i'll work
out with john evan on wednesday i'll
just do a private and work on sweeps and
escapes and [ __ ] like that you know
because i know that when all this gets
better i put more time into it sometimes
in your life you can only do something
once it's when you it's when you say to
me i haven't been able to go that's what
i have to look at you go come here for a
second there's seven days in a week
there's five classes
you couldn't make one of them that's how
busy you were and you go well you can
make one of them yeah one of them is all
you need to keep you alive if i go to
one jiu jitsu and i do two kettlebells
and take a walk around and then when i
travel i jump in the pool i did my quota
for the week i stretched
i got the blood going you know and uh
it was just really weird i i moved into
this apartment and i knew what i had to
do man i really had to go for it as a
comedian i had a day job
god knows what the [ __ ] i did i know
drugs were involved you know i know
drugs weren't involved i'm not gonna lie
to anybody and tell you that at that
point i was still a [ __ ] nomad i was
still a [ __ ] renegade so
but it got to the point where i
respected comey
i got to respect it
and i knew that there was no fun no
money no sucky
no sucky no [ __ ] that meant if i
didn't get on stage it was just like
when you were a kid
and you told your mom you didn't go to
school at three o'clock you tried to
leave and she goes where are you going
to play
you didn't go to school today you're
sick yeah yeah but i feel better that ah
i can't take it you're like holy [ __ ]
she [ __ ] me yeah you were sick at
eight i wouldn't want you to go out and
get sick yeah do you understand me
you're like [ __ ] you know yeah so i knew
in my mind
there was no cocaine until i got on
stage
and i had built this thing when i was in
boulder and and it was really weird i
was having a hard time that guy matt
barry matt woods insulted me and told me
i should just quit if i wasn't gonna
commit and that really fueled me and at
that point i was going anywhere to do
comedy i was going to poetry readings i
was a [ __ ] animal
and i wasn't getting anywhere you know
hbo wasn't calling you know i had 18
minutes of material but hbo wasn't
calling
you know and it's so frustrating for
people at home that whatever you want to
do whether it's ballet
and i would [ __ ] go home and then at
that time there was a comedy newspaper
and i would read the paper at the back
of the paper it had all the comedy clubs
and i would circle the ones where i
wanted to go and i would cry
because in my mind i was ready jesus
christ i was so far from being ready
yeah but in my mind i was ready i just
need hbo to see me or jay leno or
somebody and i'm gonna make it you know
and i think back at those times now i'm
like well how [ __ ] [ __ ] was i
was i [ __ ] crazy you know those
leasing yeah there's people who had
three or four years they're running with
people but you always got to catch up
some people are more gifted than others
in the beginning and they but somewhere
along the line that harder worker if you
slack
i'll catch up to you and that's exactly
what happened there was a ton of people
who were better than me and that the
mechanics and i don't even think i'm
that good i just got the mechanics and
the basics down
my voice is higher these are little
things you learn throughout the year but
that apartment lee
that apartment meant so much to me
like the day i die i guarantee my
spirit's gonna want to go to that
apartment just say goodbye because
my heart was broken in that like i was
at my bottom ever that's where i lived
when i punched john that's where i lived
when i was fighting with my wife when
the cops came there were so many
breakdowns that my addiction was [ __ ]
horrible that
it was a horrible medicine on paper you
should hate that apartment no because i
owe it a lot i owed a lot because it
didn't kill me i didn't die in that
[ __ ] thing you know that apartment
i still remember getting in my car
telling the landlord i'm coming back in
three months i loved that apartment that
much
it was so nitty so gritty and it smelled
like pain and it was clean there was no
mice it was [ __ ] clean brand new
carpet the paint i had a tv i had a
bench for the dinner table
so if you came over to either take the
weights off but when i was there i put
the weights on i had a sony trainer
trying i would lift weights and i do
bench press and bent over rows i had two
dumbbells and i would lift weights that
was my living room i had a couch i
bought for 30 bucks and a fan i had the
air conditioner room and in that
refrigerator there was never food not
once in the two years or three years i
lived there it was just fat tire that's
when i used to drink two fat tires for
every eight ball
you got a system in those days i did
so you know it's i think about that
apartment and i think about uh
the pain i had in that apartment how i
felt [ __ ] stuck and i really wasn't i
was just making my plan
you know fidel went into the mountains
to make his plan mm-hmm took him like
three years to make his plan then there
was no stopping
you know and that's what i was doing in
that little [ __ ] apartment so for
people who thought i was procrastinating
or whatever
i was just setting up my mind for what
was coming when i left that apartment i
never looked back very comedy i never
ever looked back it was like that was my
basic training i did it on mondays i
used to go to an australian bar it
wasn't really australian it was just an
australian theme yeah they had a stage
and then the back back back they had a
little room built into the wall like a
cave and there'd be ten people there on
monday and i go to every monday and do
15 20 minutes
on sundays i used to go to a square line
do you know what line dance is yeah they
used to have a line dancing class at
some country bar
and i would go there and that's from
seven to eight they did comedy after
country line dancing i would just drive
that a bomb but i went every sunday
tuesdays i go to club 56 in commerce
city
they gave me a commerce they gave you a
25 gift certificate
for food so you and plus they bought
your dinner that night
so you could either drink or whatever
and then i hit somebody with a
microphone in the head and they 69 out
there whatever 86 me out of that and
then on thursdays was
what's the mexican bar in burbank
a craw el torito oh my gosh the
alternative horrible those [ __ ]
things yeah you eating there your
[ __ ] intestine comes out of your
[ __ ] you gotta tuck it back in it's
this i went there for happy hour
somebody told me about two years ago go
to the happy hour i went there with my
wife to the one across from the tonight
show i almost [ __ ] died a herpes no
what do you mean no no then the food
there it's horrible horrible but they
used to have an open mic on thursday
nights and they give you dinner
and a gift certificate for the following
week
so that's what i did every thursday it
was 50 miles from my house i would
borrow three dollars for gas for the
acura
and i would drive all the way down you
drive there for a free meal in the
entire days in those days you had to and
friday and saturday i wouldn't do comedy
because that's professional comedian
that so sometimes i grabbed the guest
set but i was so [ __ ] frustrated
because i wanted more and i wanted it
fast
but that uh
place taught me patience so sometimes
you just have to uh i know i get a lot
of emails from people and they're young
people and they want to do this and they
want to do that and they get frustrated
i got some really disturbing emails this
week
and you know listen man when it's like
lee said when you lose your keys and you
get frustrated that's when you're not
going to find them
it's when you sit down make a plan take
you know and it's tough for a guy like
me to tell you because i never do this
but i do know
that a man without a plan is not a
[ __ ] man so whatever you're trying to
get yourself into ballet writing [ __ ]
stand up tiptoe dancing don't [ __ ]
know bow and arrows
you know it's uh it's a process and it's
a slow [ __ ] process and if you want
to rush it yeah you'll make some quick
strides but you still have to put the
timing at the end so
you know what i'm saying let me give
some shout outs cops there's no call
tonight this is straight oh gee gangster
you know what i'm talking about
that squad australia the rest of the
death squad community i [ __ ] love you
[ __ ] inside billy's head joe
aaron my buddy wwf guy mustafa ochoa i
like it leo hernandez and steven buse
your bad
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] i also
want to give a shout out to anik this
weekend i slept three hours uh
sunday got off the plane went home did
the turn around 180 and stayed awake all
[ __ ] day and i felt tremendous i
didn't take a nap i went to dinner with
the family i went to the park with the
baby on it works guys i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired of talking about how on it
works
i'm sick of [ __ ] tired sick and
[ __ ] tired whether it's the shroom
tech the alpha [ __ ] brain the ropes
they're coming out with new [ __ ] they
just did a a a breakthrough not a
breakthrough a press release on the on
the on the alpha brain you know the
shroom tech sport i took the shroom tech
uh whatever immune because i was going
to be on the plane and disneyland and
disneyville with all those [ __ ] kids
so i took [ __ ] shroom tech immune for
the plane and stuff guys if you're not
[ __ ] around without it you're
slipping you're really slipping go to
the honor go to honor.com look at all
the [ __ ] they got available then go to
joeydears.net and there's a box there go
to that box and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h you're ten percent off plus
you get on the list they gotta stay on
the program where we send you stuff at
the first of the month honor is great
we're not [ __ ] around go to honey.com
go to joeydears.net look at the tour
dates maybe i'm coming to your [ __ ]
hometown whatever the hell you want to
jump up and down and take another boat
uncle joey lee's going to austin with me
[ __ ] yeah you know [ __ ] like that
go to joeydears.net and see what we got
also for you [ __ ] bearded
[ __ ] lee included dollar shave
club dollar shave club [ __ ] listen
people hit me up with emails every week
thanking me for anything anything
whether it's dollar shave club hulu on
it because they know i don't [ __ ] around
go to dollar shave club they got three
different packages to you why are you
[ __ ] around they can make you look
like liberace look at me i'm an ugly
[ __ ] but the skin is looking a
lot better you think that's because i'm
doing something i'm drinking water but
that shaved butter tremendous for the
ingrown [ __ ] hairs okay the shavers
they come one dollar six dollar and nine
dollars three different packages for
your [ __ ] budget you know what you
can't do the dollar one you can't do a
dollar a month which is 12 a year then
you know what you deserve to grow a
beard and fall asleep and wake up when
you're 80 like everything about frame
your [ __ ] momo they got a six dollar
plan you get the razor once a month plus
you get four packages how many razors
would you have four razors a month with
two [ __ ] blades if you get the nine
dollar package you get the four razors
with the double blades and the aloe
strip you'll look tremendous also for
the next couple dollars some extra
adidas you get the one wipe charlie's
your [ __ ] you can wipe your nuts out
you wash come off of tits whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do and the tits will
smell like peppermint guaranteed by a
dollar shave club go to the dollar shave
club box on joey diaz.net and press in
church
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get your [ __ ] uh
deal one dollar six dollars and nine
dollars if you join through or stop
[ __ ] around stop kidding yourself
orlando was [ __ ] great this weekly
yeah
you know there was a lot of jews at that
hotel they must pass over they got like
it was passed over yeah like a ten
percent code or three percent and you
called me from that bar and i was like
that's exactly why i don't take jewish
women
and you know the jewish women let me
tell you something i've always been a
bad a fan of jewish women i love them i
love them i know they're dirty they
smell like [ __ ] matzo ball soup feet
and [ __ ] i love all that nasty stuff but
then you have the other side of those
jewish women that look like me
they wear slippers you ever see the size
of their [ __ ] feet if you wear 300 if
you weigh over 250 [ __ ] pounds don't
put slippers on all right your feet are
flat and [ __ ] disgusting especially
if you're a [ __ ] woman if you weigh
over 190 pounds do me a favor don't wear
[ __ ] slippers on your feet your feet
are [ __ ] up in that big put combat
boots on stop embarrassing yourself you
even see a big chick and she comes out
with that hunk of [ __ ] foot it looks
like a [ __ ] man's foot what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you if you're awake it
looks like a hunk of [ __ ] foot what's
wrong with you women i love your debt
but if you're as big as i am please wear
[ __ ] combat boots don't show nobody
your hopes
don't show nobody those [ __ ] folks
those jewel hoops were [ __ ] ginormous
bro yeah they had the black things on
their head with the long skirts okay all
of them had [ __ ] ugly feet yeah there
was a jew at the gym that was on the
treadmill i was checking on their feet
[ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] this [ __ ] couldn't
even climb a tree with those [ __ ]
things usually you could hoof up the
[ __ ] tree with those nails oh my god
i don't mind look i don't mind coming on
your feet
i don't want to suck them and smell them
like these disgusting people right when
you pull out you give them a little jack
to the feet women love that [ __ ] a
little something for late night
right on the feet sure i've never had
the desire to do that that's because
you're a [ __ ] half a [ __ ] mama
that's why you never want to stay what
are you doing
you walk around like you just pull it
out you go give me that foot
[ __ ] what you [ __ ] crack a nut right
on that foot it's all over the shot yeah
i get together where you're slipping
it's monday night how bad was the fight
there were a lot of kids on the flight
[ __ ] half the plane was filled with
kids jumping up and down everybody wants
to be mickey mouse
but you know what man i had a great time
in the land and the food was tremendous
you know ufc put job at a great hotel
so i got the mucho joe i stay on the
14th floor i don't buy nobody it was 32
for [ __ ] the breakfast buffet i went
down there that was my favorite phone
call of the year i'm tremendous he
called me he's like lee
how much do you think a bagel was locked
is
and i was like oh this is gonna be good
i was like ten dollars you're like 19
you're just reading the menu
chicken noodle soup
sixteen dollars for chicken noodle soup
eighteen for pasta fazool
45 for a [ __ ] small steak oh it was
39 for steak and eggs
how's that one yeah home service is a
lot but it was 32 i don't need room
service i refuse to [ __ ] pay 39 extra
i don't like food in my room can you
believe that
yeah i can see that i don't like food
because you probably don't have them
cleaned during the week i don't like
food in my room even if i haven't
cleaned i don't want nobody in my
[ __ ] room right but i came back and i
took my wife to dinner well my wife was
one that said we're gonna have to eat
the baby
and we had a coupon for already mornings
i got like 10 [ __ ] coupons we went to
artie morton's place is empty we got
three o'clock for a reason the baby i
don't it's you know she's she's [ __ ]
moves around
go to heart remains there's three
waitresses working i sit down
next thing you know
the [ __ ] place is empty
lee we're the only ones in there
they're in a cell in that a couple comes
in
they put them right behind me yeah
then a table of six came and they put
them right to my right right there the
guy's head was right there i couldn't
finish my me i was so [ __ ] furious
i couldn't finish my meal why do people
do that and i called her outside when i
was outside playing with the baby i go
listen when somebody's paying 40 bucks
for a steak they don't want to sit next
time i don't give a [ __ ] what management
tells you you think those people you sat
next to a baby are [ __ ] happy right
now
and she looked at me and she never even
thought about that yeah they just they
just they
cut all the servers so like all right
just say everyone in that one it was
three or four [ __ ] no i don't want
people sitting next oh no ever again
yeah and i told you don't i don't and
the manager came over he's all right i
go no it was all right so they put
[ __ ]
you know the jackson six next to me i
don't need these [ __ ] people next to
me man this is rude i got my baby i feel
bad for them
wasn't feeling bad for me i was feeling
bad for them
the waitress didn't [ __ ] plan
and that's part of these people they're
not trained anymore but you understand
that my wife is like don't train them no
no that's not training that's common
sense
you hear my kid yelling and screaming
why would you put a table of sticks next
to [ __ ] nice nice white people next
to the [ __ ] baby
i wouldn't do that i'd say come over
here deep get the [ __ ] away from that
[ __ ] painty ass baby that's what i
would say
to get an extra tip seriously yeah i
don't want to put you that's what a
small that's what a real hustler does
come here
most waiters will put you next to the
baby i don't want to put you over there
he's a cute he's a great kid she's a
great kid
but you guys read i don't want no
[ __ ] kid dribbling and [ __ ]
running around that's okay
most people go that's okay no it's not
once you've given birth and you've had
your kid you don't want to hit somebody
else's [ __ ] kid right you just say it
out of being polite you know what i'm
saying but me i never i would never take
my child to a movie that's just me
because i would hate to impose on other
people that's why i made i had my wife
make the reservation for three
because i know mercy's a [ __ ]
nightmare she wants to run around she
wants to you know she was banging the
[ __ ] plate with the [ __ ] thing the
macaronis were going up in the air i pay
i'll drop an extra 20 or 30 on a [ __ ]
tip just to have her there yeah that's
not the point the point is
i don't want to sit next to her it's
like when me and we'd all go on the road
me eddie bravo tate duncan ahri and joe
we got a table of six gorillas and you
put a family with six kids next to us
it's not gonna work out for you yeah
because we're gonna talk loud that's
just stupid that's common [ __ ] sense
that's the other thing that's been
forgotten about this country it's just
common
[ __ ] sense
this isn't brain surgery after this [ __ ]
this is common sense we're talking about
podcasting today and the mistakes people
make with podcasting and it's like this
is common sense this is and these are
people who went to college who took
marketing classes and took all these
high-level classes that didn't bring
nothing from it because you know what
bro you can learn all you want but
unless you do
once you start doing see my background
is from drug dealing
and this drug dealing car sales all
mixed into one thing and now i've
translated into this comedy and this is
why i get up at six in the morning and i
tweet and this is why i do the things i
do i love doing it i enjoy doing all
this [ __ ] but i can't you know if if
you're funny and you have something to
say you have a podcast
you're not gonna find it by osmosis bro
if i want people to come to my san jose
show or my vegas show july 18th i gotta
talk about it lee i gotta post it that's
what i didn't do for years it's not
blowing my own horn i can't do that you
don't know how people do it but i can't
expect you to come and be a part of
something if i don't talk about it
and i have friends that that podcast
they don't people don't listen to them
and then they get mad they go i don't
know what's going on well i looked at
your twitter feed
there's nothing about your podcast
you're wishing your niece a happy
[ __ ] birthday but your niece don't
put no [ __ ] money in your pocket you
follow him yeah
you understand i'm trying to [ __ ]
save you here listen man and i don't
want people to think this but i'm trying
to it's not all about money but it's all
about getting ahead and it's the same
[ __ ] difference that's what we're all
trying to do but when we slip into that
thing then we oh well my life isn't
about money well what is it about how
are you going to get the [ __ ] eat how
are you going to get the nice things
that you want how are you going to put
your kid in high school how are you
going to get the shoes you want how are
you going to take your girl from the
vegas league that don't come from
[ __ ] osmosis
right you have to make moves to get that
money right you could be nice
if you're nice you're not going to be
able to go to vegas when you're a nice
person you're never going to be able to
go to vegas because you're not making
money you're not sticking up for
yourself you're not telling people what
you're worth and what your value is
correct i'm not correct that's right
yeah and i think that's the difference
between
for the restaurant example i think
that's the difference between a
corporate restaurant and a guy who owns
a restaurant because a corporate
restaurant like morton's they probably
have a book that they give to all the
hostesses and they say he sit in here
and they have a guy who's been there
training them but if you owned your
restaurant you'd probably tell they
wouldn't have to worry about corporate
rules or whatever and you could just
tell them don't sit
don't sit anybody next to anybody else
but what i understand is corporate is
corporate i want the best restaurant in
corporate so i'm going to incorporate
what i have to offer into my waiters and
their staff and the management team
you know this little i'm not in the
restaurant business but i know different
things arne morton first of all i was
missing a million dollars put people at
the bar let them have a drink first then
move them i don't give a [ __ ] get them
to go with that iced tea at the bar
first slowing the [ __ ] down there's so
many different [ __ ] things you know
they come up to you they tell you the
special like it's memorized i don't want
to hear that [ __ ] put some [ __ ]
flavor to it yeah yeah do you understand
me yeah i could do these ads how they
want me to do them and you know what
nobody would go to dollar shave club
nobody would go to [ __ ] army they
wouldn't if i tell you the [ __ ] they
want me to [ __ ] save people i would
embarrass myself with the [ __ ] that they
write stuff these speeches that these
marketing companies write these
executives these [ __ ] morons because
they sell from what's in a book they
don't sell from what's in their heart
they don't [ __ ] put hulu whatever i
can sit here and hulu plus is great they
offer great movies no you [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is what they [ __ ] offer i'm
saving you [ __ ] money okay at the end
of the week you want to save a little
[ __ ] guidance that's what uncle is
here to do you know how to do a thousand
other things you could watch hulu plus
on your roku on your smartphone on your
ipad you can binge you can do whatever
[ __ ] you want with your life you can
watch 20 shows you can take the day off
you can whack off in the [ __ ]
bathroom at north hollywood park and
watch a [ __ ] movie i don't think they
have porn on hulu plus but my point is
they got movies they got [ __ ] uh
what's the other [ __ ] they got they got
yours
they got original programming now they
got all this stuff but if i read you the
[ __ ] that they want me to read you go
johnny joey how [ __ ] corny are you
you ever listen to something and
somebody goes speaking of the weather
you know umbrellas r us and you're like
oh my god that's horrible just go [ __ ]
the rain you know what i got the best
umbrellas in town for you and that's the
same thing i got to offer you with hulu
plus i don't have to [ __ ] be corny
about hulu plus i'm giving you a great
deal it's 7.99 a month and i'm giving
you two weeks for free if you go to the
webpage you get one week for [ __ ]
free [ __ ] that [ __ ] go through the
church and get two weeks what are they
good you know joeydears.net they go to
the box and when they press in joey joey
j-o-e-y bam just like that two weeks on
the arm for free who gives you two weeks
worth of [ __ ] two weeks so it's 7.99 a
month so i'm basically giving you four
dollars for [ __ ] free four hours
who's giving you four [ __ ] dollars
all right that's what they do hulu plus
you know why they do that because they
know once you get in there you're gonna
[ __ ] love it they got everything you
like to watch plus [ __ ] you haven't
watched it you've thought about it
you've heard about oh my god i've never
seen this show well bam david [ __ ] is
you want me to read you a list i can
read you a list of what it says on here
and two dogs i just broke it down for
you understand me you're losing money
you're wasting your [ __ ] time go to
hulu plus get two weeks for free and
after that 7.99 a month for [ __ ] life
what are they pressing the box with joey
joey when you go to joey dears.net from
now on you're just not gonna go to hulu
plus or the or the on that box or you're
not gonna go to [ __ ] uh uh dollar
shave club you also gonna go and if you
need a mug or a [ __ ] patch or don't
show them [ __ ] [ __ ] them go to the got
something they got eyes any of these
things you go you like it that's it
that's how you [ __ ] do it but if i
read you what these [ __ ] wanted
me to tell you oh my god we'd be here
for two hours and we get nowhere you go
joey get the [ __ ] off the mic but that's
the thing so for the restaurants
the first guy who owned it probably
agrees with you but then they have more
and then they start making a little bit
of money and let's say they they let a
server go off the rails what if that
service is [ __ ] and he he he get uh
insult somebody so they have all those
they have all those things in place now
so no one gets offended and and no one
and no one goes outside the box to me
they can play with service good service
and good work you'll get offended when a
waiter is good there's nothing bad that
having a work a [ __ ] bad weight if i
tell you i want my steak well done you
bring it back to me raw i'm agitated i'm
[ __ ] hungry now i gotta send my food
back that's a bad experience yeah okay
he didn't do his [ __ ] job if i'm
sitting there and i don't have something
in front of me that's a bad [ __ ]
waiter i'm always communicating with
them i'm always asking how they are i'm
not i'm not going to mcdonald's let me
ask you this
what if mcdonald's what if the guy at
mcdonald's
hired a guy paid them 10 bucks an hour
to ask you how your meal was they had
that where i grew up and not mcdonald's
they don't have anything yeah they sure
yeah and they have a guy that would come
up to you bring you a straw ask you
everything was he wiped down the tables
you know he really wiped down the tables
because he had to be like a manager
looking guy
that you know it's like when i went to
chicago i seen the owner of the
restaurant walking around shaking
people's hands saying thank you and
that's why he owns that restaurant any
of these shane places they get so
nervous about it and they they want to
be able to place anybody in they don't
want anybody making noises anybody could
be a server at a chain place
i remember i wanted to be a server and
another server bartender at
one of those chains in 84 before i left
and they wanted me to be a cook first
so i think b a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was it it's one of those
popular changes chili's applebee's one
of those it was way before those okay
and he's coach chain
and they wanted you to be a cook first
before you uh
became a bartender i was already at bart
in the city i'm like oh okay i'll be a
cooking i went down and looked at that
food and i'm like dog i can't serve this
[ __ ]
yeah but here's the other thing all
right so a general manager comes into a
restaurant he wants to apply
his policies or the uh the corporation's
policies yeah the corporate policies and
he also wants somewhere around that he
wants that restaurant to reflect what
he's about whether he's a hard worker
whether he's a
customer service based everybody has a
different where they come from when
you're an mma fighter you come from muay
thai boxing wrestling background jiu
jitsu background probably this guy's
customer service maybe this guy was a
chef at one time he's into presentation
they turn that restaurant into what they
have now also if i'm a corporate
corporation and i put you as the general
manager i'm gonna give you a taste at
the end of the year so i'm gonna give
you
six percent of the overall gross at the
end of the year right
i'm gonna put if if that's what
motivates me that's what i think outside
the box
well that's what you think so but what
they think is
is they have a setup plan that they know
works and their restaurant will make a
million dollars
they could put it and they could have
they could have people doing what you
say
but if some people don't like that some
of the older people aren't don't want
that sort of thing they just want the
same experience they've had at legal
seafoods forever
if they lose money then it gets fired he
knows he's not gonna lose money he's
only going to do better leave but it's
like having a day job
look when i go to legal seafood in
boston that [ __ ] general manager
nobody came beside the waiter and asked
me how my food was but if that general
manager took two minutes and came and
that's how his food was and did you try
the dessert no we don't have room for
this way to say
you haven't tried the [ __ ] general
marmalade here with the shrimp flavor in
the [ __ ]
no i haven't you don't know what you're
missing let me give you a sample
that's what i'm doing exactly my point
even if they get fired it's five dollars
out of their pocket it's gonna sell
we're looking at the bottom [ __ ] line
lee if i put what i'm talking about not
everything is black and white
that's why you have failures because in
this world today in this corporate world
today everything is black and white yeah
but it's not black and white and that's
what i'm telling you i'm agreeing with
you i'm just saying this is why you're
doing this no these guys are scared
everybody's scared losing their [ __ ]
job so then when they do a bad job
they're gonna get fired anyway
i'd rather
go the extra mile
and try because i could always fight for
it i could always go listen
they didn't like me because i gave away
a dessert but in my defense i was the
highest grossing [ __ ] harley morton's
in the region for six years yeah and the
bottom line speaks loudest yeah the
bottom line speaks loudest in those
places so this is what i'm trying to say
there's some certain people that'll be
[ __ ] goats and sheep all their
[ __ ] lives and that's the result
they'll get when they when they retire
they get a gold watch and everybody else
is stealing making millions but they got
a gold watch for [ __ ] working 30
years like a [ __ ] animal you
understand me the goal is to get the
[ __ ] out it's like the comedy story
people get mad at me because i don't go
to the comment store the bottom line of
the comedy store is getting out of there
it's not staying there right yeah it's
getting out of there it's going through
there making your point and getting the
[ __ ] out of there if you go back in
there after like seven years and you're
dangling around i don't know what world
you
you should have moved on a little bit
you know what i'm saying like yeah i
know ari still goes there but larry goes
you know during the week the [ __ ] around
but it's not his end-all be-all right
you know you move on you move out of
that [ __ ] who had that joke it was like
i think with the cat williams joke he
doesn't [ __ ] with people who are still
selling weed
some i was watching one of his old
specials and he's [ __ ] great but uh
no it's it's uh
it's crazy and it's like i was calling i
called american airlines today because
we we i was booking my thing
and every window in ilc they were
charging you 30 bucks you couldn't
choose a seat other than why did you
call them why'd you go online i did go
online i booked my ticket but you
couldn't choose a window or an aisle
seat without paying extra money so i was
like oh maybe i'll call them and do it
and she's like oh no every every window
and i like and they get you at every
angle now so like the corporate so i
just didn't choose a seat and it gave me
uh a window i think for free
but it was like if you wanted to put you
17 and 22. so i'm in the back
i'm on the way there you're in 17. i'm
on the on the way there i'm on 22
i think on the way back even 17 yeah
but but it's just uh you know the window
both times when i'm in the aisle
that's not bad
at least you're not in the middle
well i can't be in the middle but
it's uh
it's just it they
they have so many corporate policies now
that just are the most stupid and it's
it's it's the same thing how if you work
at a place
everyone has that boss who they hate
who's always going to tell telling
somebody or or you didn't feel like it's
a big joke from uh office spaces
a little tps report and he has 10 bosses
coming around oh he didn't fill out the
tps report correct he's like well i got
my [ __ ] work done and he every time
he makes a mistake he has seven bosses
to come and yell at him it's [ __ ]
it's it's a terrible play it's a
terrible cheese but not enough india's
no it's it's it's easily i love it
that's the expression too many cheese
not enough [ __ ] indians that's that's
the bottom line with that [ __ ] yeah
it's amazing when uh
you go out now how different things are
you know uh today did you see the uh
diane sawyer had a thing about
canadian air how they throw your luggage
i saw that you see that i didn't see her
thing but i saw that they did that yeah
and now the the canadian air called the
luggage guy back and they went into
if your
luggage is damaged or your luggage is
lost if you don't call in 24 hours you
don't get dick
you get like i don't even know how much
they give you for your luggage even if
you got ten thousand dollars worth of
clothes they give you like a thousand
dollars or something like that yeah
they're [ __ ] cold-blooded but this
happens because we let it happen
this happens because we let it happen
and i
so i get i'm giving you 25 for my
luggage
i'm giving you 25 dollars each way each
way and you're throwing my luggage and
if you lose it i got 24 hours to report
that's you trying to [ __ ] tell me
yeah
i have to call the post office because i
noticed my my my tax check didn't get
deposited like one didn't one didn't and
luckily i have tracking on it it was
supposed to go to san francisco it went
to san francisco and then i went back
and forth to baltimore
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that so
i'm nervous i have to call them tomorrow
find out what the [ __ ] is happening with
my [ __ ] tax check
but it's like luckily they have tracking
on it so put the tracking on it i did
because i'm [ __ ] i don't i wanted to
make sure they got it
but uh
yeah it's it's uh it's terrible like the
airlines luckily they don't fly as much
as you do
but it's uh like they're coming at you i
i you know i keep my contact with them
to a limited i know
you know i just know what the [ __ ] with
them and not how not to [ __ ] with them
you know i know that's why i pay the
full thing
i i always try to do something better
because it's just it's a [ __ ]
nightmare i would love i feel bad
i feel really bad i would love to
do a video of you calling american
airline because i called them today and
it took 10 minutes to get through all
their menus
of like what's your flight agent yeah
agent it keeps going agent i keep going
agent
agent
one more question is it is your flight
in 50 states north america or canada yes
it is thank you and they put you i don't
even [ __ ] with you
jose agent
agent
you have an agent
i don't know the agent i don't
understand agent
agent
agent
and they'll [ __ ] put them on okay if
you didn't uh we'll put you connected i
[ __ ] torment him i say agent 80
[ __ ] the beginning agent agent agent
and they go okay we're connecting that's
it don't [ __ ] it around don't tell them
where i'm going none of your [ __ ]
business where i'm going it's like when
you call people you ever call somebody
and they go who my ass who's calling
don't matter
what is this about
don't matter let me talk to him yeah
i tell him just like that okay yeah
don't matter what do you care it's only
a [ __ ] business yeah i got vd in my
[ __ ]
what do you give a [ __ ] about i got bd
and my muffler what do you [ __ ] care
about now put the doctor on it's under
your [ __ ] business while i'm calling
you that's the and all they call and
they say he's not available then would
you ask me what my name was
the [ __ ] is wrong don't ask me
when they asked me now is he available
who's i say it's called is he available
yeah you know the other day i was on the
when i worked for boulder toyota
years ago
there was a there was a you couldn't
take sales calls from any phone you had
to call the operator she goes i go to
sales you have to call the operator and
you got to tell it what phone booth you
wanted okay either phone booth one or
two as soon as you picked the phone or
tape recorder one on
and they had a script
and if you stuck to that [ __ ] script
lee
you would sell a thousand cars a month
but everybody would say and i went to
battle with the the guy who ran the
program and one day he took me to lunch
and he goes joey listen to me you're a
great you're a hustler
you show up on time your shoes always
shine you know
we've spent millions into this
how about i work with you on this and
i'll watch you do the money and we would
sit together and he'd listen
like that with speakers and i talked to
the person and he'd say stick to that
and they would even diagram it if they
say that go back to that
like that's how much
and what it was was designed to not give
any answers hi who am i speaking with
lisa hi lee what can i do for you today
i'm calling about the 82 mustang what's
the mileage on it's blue it's beautiful
it's four-cylinder it's got 390 uh
horsepower air conditioning i got it
from some lady the rims uh what's the
mileage on it you have to smell the
interior of this [ __ ] car
what's the mouth the tires are blank are
brand new we did a 21 two point
inspection on it what's the mileage on
it let me ask you this what time do you
want to come in i have a 2 30 and i have
a four o'clock this car is not gonna
last you wanna come in here at one
o'clock what's the mileage on it do you
wanna come in here at one o'clock sir
this car is going hold on one second i
have something on the lot and i mean dog
you sold the [ __ ] car the other day i
sat there and listened to my wife called
for an office yeah and next you know
she's telling them i'm a stand-up and a
podcast and i go hang up the phone she's
like what hang up the phone you gave him
too much information you just lost the
battery you don't think him dick but
they asked [ __ ] go around it you
don't have to tell nobody dick
you don't gotta tell nobody dick what do
you tell them all that [ __ ]
information for stick to your guns you
know and that's how i do that reverse
who am i who's i saying is calling who
you might talking to
who am i talking to and what has it got
to do with the situation i have is the
doctor available to talk right now
is he available no he's not then i'll
call back there's no reason to give him
my [ __ ] name
right you want no names as well what do
you do like the grocery store when they
say can they have your number and stuff
i don't have a number
don't worry about it it's like when you
go to starbucks you're in that time you
want us to fill it to the top yeah i
want you to let it go over and boil on
my [ __ ] fingers no give it some
[ __ ] air
what's your email i don't [ __ ] know
it's eight in the morning give me my
coffee and ask me [ __ ] questions
okay what's with the [ __ ] questions
at eight in the morning i come in here
for a cup of coffee give me the [ __ ]
coffee is it two dollars do what the
[ __ ] you gotta do what's with the
[ __ ] questions
i think you might have broken your hand
like that guy in the ufc fight the other
night you know me i'm the toughest
[ __ ] man he's ain't gonna hurt my
knuckles
it's it's really amazing how we give too
much information only to give nobody
information nothing you think you do
steamroll these [ __ ] it's like
you're a parrot
i'm a parrot there's times people email
me they're talking about the winter and
i start talking about the summer when
they read that email they're like [ __ ]
we tried to confuse him he confused us
also do not forget about
escapepodtank.com
for all your flotation tank needs do you
understand me i don't give a [ __ ] you're
going to go to uh wherever you're going
to go on float and pay per session
get escape pod tank go to their website
they have commercial tanks they have
personal tanks for your house they have
industrial tanks you know and i don't
know if you guys know about flotation
systems or whatever go to
escapepodtank.com
look at what they got to offer if they
got something that you like let's say
you got questions call jeremy there's a
1-800 number jeremy i'll answer the
phone i'll help you it's customer
service is going to win you over you
know why i went with them you know why i
work with them because they save you two
to three to four grand and the customer
service is [ __ ] tremendous
that is the most expensive that is the
most important thing sometimes
something's more expensive than others
but i'll go with that guy because of the
customer service you're gonna lose
you're gonna you're gonna go with
somebody over five dollars and when
you're calling for something they're
never gonna call you back the guy you
paid the money to he's gonna call you
back trust me i'm telling you go to
escape podtank.com they're not going to
charge you more they're going to save
you money but jeremy when you call the
800 number he'll be his [ __ ] nicest
pie to you give him a cup give him a
choc give him a shot also when you
mention my name you get 250 off you want
to play in your house they'll fly out
and stall in your house they have a team
to come out to your house or you can
just order and do it yourself and sweat
and remind yourself at christmas when
you're [ __ ] doing your kids toys and
they don't bring a screw so just [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i gotta let
these people know i gotta draw a picture
of people when you're [ __ ] around
here
i'm sorry about today with the audio
sound least spectacular what he does
but sometimes the wires get crossed here
and [ __ ] the sound goes kaput and it
happens so i'm happy you people listen
to i know it's late on the east coast i
know it's late in the midwest
but [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone's
going to break out of the road and
listen to a [ __ ] podcast from time to
time i don't even know what we [ __ ]
talked about today but i know i had a
good time and listen to me it's [ __ ]
hot in here you know thank god we can
get this other office they don't turn
the air on saturday and sunday we're
going to walk into a [ __ ] oven on
monday morning but we keep it at 74. 74
does nothing when it's [ __ ] 95
outside you know what i'm saying
everybody wants to keep directing that
we need that condition at 50 [ __ ]
five yeah it's got to be freezing i want
to see you with a [ __ ] winter jacket
inside yeah what good is it having an
action there's no it's comfortable if i
want to be comfortable i'll get some
[ __ ] broke heads or something like
that all right i'm going to be [ __ ]
cold i don't even want to be the [ __ ]
sweat i'm sitting here why would i be
[ __ ] hot i felt really bad
have you do you ever pick up the
t-shirts at the t-shirt please they
don't have an ac on there i felt so bad
for the people there today i was like oh
god it's funny
yeah i was like it's [ __ ] hot in here
in nowhere no i was like oh these poor
people [ __ ] animals [ __ ] people
[ __ ] animals to say what and you're
gonna have uncomfortable employees then
when they rob you oh well he's a piece
of [ __ ] he robbed me next time
one of the nights
when i worked at night shift they said
bring a fan they turned the ac off and i
was like
[ __ ] all right
bring a [ __ ] fan so anyway as you
guys know next wednesday we're doing a
live podcast at the ice house eight
o'clock
4 30 and then the following week i'm at
the camel
back casino in santa fe with ari shafir
it's a saturday night show may 10th then
the following myself and the flying jew
from the 15th to the 17th will be at cap
city comedy club in austin texas oh [ __ ]
he'll be down there selling some [ __ ]
t-shirts eating some [ __ ] goomies and
having all that fun some goomies some
goomies a bunch of them and for you
people from the church thank you for all
the love and support you give me for
coming to the shows and
uh for just loving me and liam for what
we're doing you know we try really
[ __ ] hard here we're not some johnny
come lately [ __ ]
we try really hard here and we're happy
that you uh we know you have a lot of
[ __ ] options so for you guys to tune
in and give us the love you give us
means a lot you know so thank you very
much we'll see you guys wednesday with
ed suarez nice and early six [ __ ]
o'clock in the morning as usual we love
you [ __ ] stay black
oh [ __ ] where's the musically you're
slipping hold on i gotta i gotta read
the script again jesus christ on a
crutch now that the show is over don't
forget to sign up for hulu plus for your
free trial of hulu plus hulu plus did
you binge on thousands of hit shows
anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast to get an extended free trial of
hulu plus when you go to huluplus.com
joey or go to joeydiaz.net and click on
the hulu plus banner and don't forget to
sign up for dollarshaveclub.com get high
quality razers sent to your door every
month for a fraction of what you pay at
retail go to dollarshaveclub.com forward
slash church or go to joeyds.net and
click on the dollar shave club banner
and again thank you to escape
podtangs.com
get your flotation tank it's at your
house you don't got to float with random
people uh mention joe ideas and they're
going to save you an additional 250 off
stay black
oh [ __ ] uh-huh
oh [ __ ] wiggle funk with joy lee let's
see what you got for papa what do you
know about this joey here let me see
baby let me see what you got from good
joy what [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] look at
you let me see you do it
that's it with the hands let's see you
gotta shake that one like this
with the cowbell come on let me see if
you can do that
i just wanna dig a genie
have a great week